what's up reject nation merry christmas
so we were doing a live stream and in
the middle of the live stream
tune sandwich art spirit entertainment
dropped this video
fanny fan fanfiction
yeah i got it right episode one the
phantom like menace
tune sandwich guys guys it's tuned
sandwich like the super villain bowl
superhero bowl super showdown bowl with
a bunch of trailer spoofs they're
incredible oh yeah let's watch this
video
they they encourage reaction so hell
yeah let's see how many
characters pop up
no no no i can't be here how can i be
here
[Music]
no doctor manhattan
captain marvel oh my god too many
characters
what's going on no this can't be
happening
oh no no please no
no say something you can't be dead
you can't be dead
[Music]
no you can't be
you alive never kill me i
create you i live within you
and all that you create no i'm not here
this isn't happening i'm in fanfiction
i'm in fanfiction
you can run to the farthest corner of
the universe
but in the end you'll realize you can
never live together
there is no world where you can find
peace
heroes and villains oh god look at that
v-line
yeah man reason for being is to fight
and destroy
where's that daylight
[Music]
if you pretending you found your happily
ever after
you need to wake up it's actually sister
the bad got me the bat got me
there's a batman dream i'm not usually
the jealous type but now you've
outnumbered my mantis dreams three to
one
no i mean my bad oh now he's your bat my
baseball bat
it doesn't matter it's just a stupid
nightmare mom are you okay
what ah nuts just woke the kids
kids you're way your brother my mom mom
what's going on what's going on
but i'm up now did you have another
dream about batman no i didn't and don't
go spreading any of that around the
school
i can keep a secret i didn't tell you
and did about timmy's arm
what about jimmy's oh for
pete's sake he gave it to a girl he's in
love with
shut up mark but it's true i do love her
that's wonderful jimmy but it's not the
relevant issue here typically one gives
say a lock of one's hair an entire limb
well of course it'll grow back but not
by tomorrow what about your game
i don't think it'll make much difference
come on it's 3 a.m
montlie stop teasing your brother and
get your butt back into bed
can you tell me the story of the
invictasia again no it's bedtime please
i'll fall asleep as you tell it what a
glowing review please
[Music]
all right but just the abridged version
dad kick us
off oh his name's jimmy three years ago
dad what your forefather
me and your forehead were integral in
the emancipation of all future
fanfictions
from the clutches of the evil 24-carat
super sociopath known as oscar
we killed him and he's dead in the storm
direction
okay i guess we're skipping forward to
ted but it wasn't the end of our story
dr manhattan teleported all of us to our
own private corner of the known universe
it wasn't much to look at in the
beginning but with ego's powers and
everyone's ideas
we built a world we could all call home
drawing inspiration from our implanted
memories and backstories
we made one world out of many with
realms to suit everyone
[Music]
this is awesome like actually cool
under the sea realms above the sky
wow wow
and it was my idea to go back and see if
there was anyone we'd left behind
it turns out i had a whole bunch of
other arenas on the side
the inhabitants were very happy to see
us rejoice my friend
from this endless cycle of violence
everyone do what the sheep is doing hey
motion stop-motion characters that's
us it worked on the great authorities
all right put the twig away back you
don't want to spook the natives
i think i need a little more time to
explain the situation
after we got them all back home our
world got a whole lot bigger
literally ego increased this diameter by
twenty percent
around this time we elected the
fantastic ten a group of esteemed
individuals chosen by their peers to
best represent the needs of everyone in
matters of fanfiction policy
and the first thing they did was to
outlaw extreme acts of supernaturalism
such as mind control regeneration mass
destruction and time travel
but you know it's been eight years and i
gotta say we're scraping by without them
why weren't you two elected why indeed
your mother launched a very strong
campaign that ultimately fell short but
she is still a
killer of our community some of the
fanfiction themselves come to her for
therapy
i charge him extra it's my subtle
revenge and don't get the best part
i certainly hope i don't because the
eighth anniversary is coming up
i now pronounce you
[Music]
maui
[Music]
that's
oh dc is starting on top but it won't
end there wow that is perfectly planted
yeah it looks like they were they
actually did it sounds like our own home
and boom mr stork deposited you two in
the pumpkin patch
well mr stork should have been wearing
his raincoat wait
you skipped the part about the vault oh
the vault
well the fanfic tend to creed that
certain weapons and objects that we
brought from the arena were just too
powerful and dangerous to be loose in
the world
so they locked them up in a secure vault
that can only be opened by the combined
authentication of the fanfiction
but that's navigation no cerebral palsy
inside the vault
no what did i just say that's not fair i
didn't get a say in any of this
yeah well that's life kiddo you wake up
in a strange world and you're going to
either beat them or join them
now go to sleep mom
am i a hero or villain what
why are you asking that it's just the
kids at lunch were choosing teams based
on whether their parents were heroes or
villains
and they said since both my parents are
andy heroes that makes me an annie hero
and they're all auntie anti-heroes
you're seven years old you're not heroes
or villains you're kids
you should just be having fun together
it's a well-adjusted point of view get
along right
yeah of course good because otherwise
you missed the whole point of the story
we fought so you don't have to i know
mom sleep
now oh
[Music]
at the moment and actually you wouldn't
happen to be a size eight slipper
what are you serious
of course i can handle it i'm on the
case
they get in trouble for making justices
i have no idea like blood
representatives
intelligent hero this is his story
that must have been the poster in the
bedroom i know you're already serving 53
consecutive life sentences in supermax
but if you don't play ball with the d.a
i'm going to make things hard for you
what are you gonna do send me to the
electric chair
send you you're in it
i wasn't really feeling that one let's
run it from her line
also not to question the script but it's
this accurate due process it's not the
scene fanfic
just called for you
[Music]
god of thunder
i'm on my way hey grab some battery
packs
thought order is going mobile
empire strikes back building
wow this is so inventive who found the
body i did mom
oh dear
be taken out
four that was you thor hell are you
doing here
no it appears there's been a hotter side
fanfic 10 no less want me on the case
i'm on the case well i guess i didn't
think you could handle it you're not a
real detective
how many homicide cases have you solved
none
this is the first we've ever had well
i've solved over a hundred enough for
syndication
those aren't real cases it's a stupid tv
show
so it's my 100 plus stupid tv showcases
versus your zero cases of any kind
well i think that makes me the most
qualified yeah
there's kind of a point if you're
introducing yourself a story's assistant
why have you brought these two idiots
this is a murder investigation not some
cheap prime time escapism hello my job
doesn't stop simply because all the
fanfiction is crying out for me to
balance the scales of justice
but i swear on our mother this
investigation
is my top priority oh can we get
that again there was a plane hold up my
job doesn't stop simply i have to deal
with a dead body
but the first chance i get i'm going
straight to the fanfic 10.
there's a dead body seems that hunt has
become the hunted
hanging off the world's tallest building
well clearly he was attempting a death
defying heist to steal encrypted data
or he was just doing his job when some
jackass came along and ruined his day
tonight a window cleaner died in
gothtropolis
journal tonight i found a missing mogwai
and one of the city's most dedicated
professionals was brutally slain in the
line of duty
crying spider emoji villain could have
done this
what makes you think it was a villain
how did you all get here
well my spider sense tingled so i called
catwoman i guess she called shazam
i called everyone why didn't you turn on
the super signal isn't that what it is
always the best time to commit a crime
in gotham
or during the day it wouldn't have
mattered we'd still have arrived too
late
in the end all we could do was cover him
up all you could do was interfere with
the crime scene
we fight i've never even seen a crime
scene before is this what they look like
ew oh god wrote an article about a clock
leave the csi to the pros
knife wound in the chest
that wasn't a request that was an
observation
two knife wounds in the chest but we can
disregard the second one
we just cut our workload in half
window was broken from the inside of the
first blood and cleaning equipment down
below
why'd you put those there i didn't put
them bad they fell
it's like an airplane so what's the next
move
i take the body to the lab and start
hunting for a murderer
[Laughter]
[Music]
is
actually hey puddle i'm borrowing your
backpack
ethan hunt was murdered in the city last
night
moided are they sure he didn't just fall
off the side of a plane
since he was stabbed whilst window
cleaning bad way to go
uh maybe they made a mistake wouldn't be
the first case of the fancy times having
a printer attraction
so what are your plans for this fine day
lara croft invited me to go to
training is the coolest sentence ever
spoken
jolie or vikander video game version
picking it old school
well i trust you remember the deal i've
got them this time but for next week's
take your parents to school day
you're the parent they're taking to
school on that day yeesh why'd they have
to outlaw time travel
we gotta skip forward to the day they
leave home ten more years
just gotta keep our heads above water
segway
not brought anyone here before it's my
special place
i come here once a week to decompress i
thought only humans had to do that
i mean emotionally
sooner come out of the darkness like a
ghost ship
gets me every time oh my gosh
you're so deep i know babe
ariel listen to me i don't trust this
half breed
sebastian i don't understand what your
problem is
he lives under the sea has a gold
trident long flowing hair
this is my perfect match well
ignoring the exoskeleton chilling daddy
[Music]
literally what is this someone's been
dumping their trash in my ocean
that's not trash
it's pretty hard
[Music]
jones told me about it said he got an
anonymous tip
a tilt tip who made it don't know
i've created several tombs myself but
it's no fun reading when you already
know where all the people
are building tracks yeah you know poison
darts
collapsing floors bodies jumping out at
you
jones where the hell have you been you
were late so i started without you
i was right on time guys chill there's
plenty of tomb here for all of us
actually there's not i was just doubling
back because i hit a dead end
nice hey i don't want to tell you guys
how to do your hobbies but
beginners do you smell smoke
[Music]
batman which one no
it has to be these tombs are full of
fake bones and artifacts
none of it's real but batman
someone's playing a prank on us i don't
know
it looks like half of these bones have
been recently burned
how did you receive this anonymous
look someone slipped it into my fanfic
10 suggestion box
here but you can't tell the others okay
i'll get in trouble for abusing my
position ah
i knew him well lara i'm actually not
sure which batman this is but they
shared many treats
[Music]
uh-oh
[Music]
i don't know why you didn't do that
originally because it'll block the
entrance or we'll be stuck in here until
we die of thirst
oh cool
are you sure you didn't make that too
[Music]
two bodies in as many days but how long
was she down there
it can't have been more than a week i
frequented that wreck
clear the decks and i have to make sure
she's all here before she goes to the
lab
will you hurt her you savor scurvy
scallywags
okay she's all here
[Music]
their eyes are as big as that
hello you left without me grabbing
establishing
thor you're not a detective oh really
well i just detected a hint of
peevishness in your tone of voice
i'll give you a hint you son of a don't
bring mother into this did the fair
victory
did the fanfiction not confirm my
appointment
yes it is closed the case is far from
closed as you can clearly see
so what are we thinking boating accident
shark attack obviously not
she's been surgically dismembered and
dumped we'll try to reboot her and
hopefully she can tell us what happened
hello if you knew anything about
electricity you'd see she's clearly
waterlogged
what you're suggesting could fry her
circuitry so what do you suggest
well we have to dry her out first and
there's only one surefire way to try out
a complex electronic device
dudes that was my launch this is the
stupidest idea you've ever had
at the high bar we'll come back in 12
hours once she's dried out and i'll give
her a jolt for my electrodes what's the
ish
uh dudes what's
this
hella you need to come back to the lab
someone just brought in another body
[Music]
don't make a joke about vaccines
fortunately these teeth are on fire
so which one is it
[Music]
george clooney who would kill george
clooney batman
george clooney for one let's try and
restrict our suspect pool to people on
this planet
based on the carbon readings i'd say
death occurred almost
eight years ago that's almost as old as
fanfiction itself
how could no one have noticed he's been
missing all this time from my
understanding batman characters
gravitated towards valkilma batman could
kilma be the killer
kilmer's now killer what about the burn
femur also clooney's
no i can tell you straight away that
it's much more recent
because it stinks i'm scanning it now
but it will take some time to identify
did you learn anything from ethan hunt
well you were right about the cause of
death
of the two wounds in the chest no i told
you to ignore the second one
yes i got your message though
penetrated the chest i found pieces of
glass inside the wound
but thor's handiwork is not the only
mutilation this body has suffered
postmortem
it's the same as the one on a liter
where is elita
oh we left her on the black pearl for
now put her head in a bowl of rice to
dry out
you what was thor's idea look it worked
when i dropped my stock pad in the
preview hey detectives
i found a clue on clooney
in the world's leading crime drama have
taught me anything
it's to recognize the connective threads
that betray the exploits
of a serial killer
i mean that's horrible
where to now the ego center
[Music]
dudes
please consider doing so because it
costs nothing but means
everything to these two gosh wow
i don't even exist and that terrifies me
i never thought about that that's true
[Laughter]
wow such wonder about this that's
amazing it was a torn
force of whimsy i mean i gotta say
i gotta say it's been a long day uh
it's been a long day but i gotta say i
was
really really impressed with this on a
wide variety
i want to see episode two i'm so used to
you know like the trailer spoofs and
then you know the superhero bowls and
all that which have its wraparounds and
have its little story threads here or
there but they're usually like they get
a lot of these cameos and such and it's
really funny and
really inspiring to see the kind of
dedication of work they put in like it's
undoubtedly impressive but i feel like
they kind of upped their game here
because they have a real story they're
actually telling now because a lot of
times like those other ones
characters come in they have like a
punch line a punch line and a punch line
a punch there's a bunch of random punch
lines and the whole idea is to see
there's a crazy hodgepodge of people
being thrown into this lottery and then
here
i want to know the mystery murder i want
to see the cases unfold like when they
ever did the reveal of like the oscar in
the back of the necks and stuff i was
like oh
that's actually kind of a true mystery
yeah it's kind of intense man
throughout this it kept it kept bleeding
into okay this is funny and everything
but now i'm actually feeling them like
when she's first talking to oscar at the
beginning i started to get entranced i
was like
this is a pretty scary exchange and now
you know being launched into this sort
of fantasy of sorts or we don't know
exactly what the
you know reality of the reality is but
this was just so
inventive yeah and to take something
that started out with just a bunch of
referential characters coming together
in a big medley now it's also grown its
own legs into its own world and it was
so dazzling to see
them literally build the world right
before your eyes of fanfiction
this is a cool cool series concept
because people they actually
feel like characters here they weren't
just used for bits i was even endeared
to the deadpool and harley quinn
relationship seeing harley as a mom and
their personalities i love like the
incredibly sincere deadpool that we got
of he just seems really supportive and
really caring and wants to be a good dad
and he loves his wife and then harley
quinn even kind of reinventing her
getting the dynamics of the kind of
person they did with it feels like it
honors the character that we
know but they're we're exploring a
different aspect to them because to call
this fanfiction you want it to be
that combination of fan fiction but also
bring something fresh and different and
i feel like they're doing that it's like
do you have the characters who pop up in
here for little bits to do like a little
punch line or a joke when especially
when you're in a crowd of people like
when they go to the pirates of the
caribbean boat or
the fighting session you know like
little things like that but for the ones
they focus on i thought it was really
refreshing to get
some actual characters some actual
mystery to have it be exciting not based
off of watch their powers on display
you're just watching the comedy unfold
and the jokes are pretty clever for the
most part
i was gripped i i thought we were just
walking into something funny and kind of
like superhero ball but they did
something very different i'm excited
that they have a series in store here
to follow an actual narrative and
storyline because yeah
um the world that they've created by
combining other worlds
i'm blown away yeah blown away i'm very
envious of this this is very impressive
it's
funny because it is all this stuff that
we know and love and is very familiar in
pop culture and yet there is something
about it where i i caught myself part
way through that bedroom scene i was
like
oh yeah we're just watching a scene they
wrote
yeah happens to feature these characters
in a totally new situation and even
though yeah you have a bunch of familiar
stuff
and references and member berries
everywhere it also started to feel like
its own little lucid world and then part
of the surprise becomes not only picking
out who's in the background
or the thing where it's like there are
other domes with all these
stop-motion or cartoon characters and
whatnot but it also becomes about seeing
like okay how's this character now gonna
get
repurposed into the society of
fanfiction
and now i'm thinking about this way more
than i ever expected to and yeah
like i love they built a world exactly
and it feels tangible it doesn't feel
like oh you just took a bunch of notable
characters and slapped them together
like this
is one of those things that makes me
really excited for the possibilities of
what fan fiction can do
and i really hope that they don't run
into any copyright troubles
because they have in the past so i'm
open with this one especially because
this is just so like
imaginative and it is its own story and
it is even though it's not like the real
thing really exciting to see like a
skyline that has
a spider-man statue and a wonder woman
statue and all these different things
and an actual mystery that i want to see
a second installment of like i'm excited
for this series now to continue and
they hinted at that i feel like with
like the super villain bowl kind of
seemed
more intricate or like it was building
on top of the hero bowl and all that
these guys will have their own
you know like tv series before long well
i'm wondering how they're going to
structure their episodes because they
got so many characters to toy with like
are these the main ensemble cast or are
we going to
focus on different characters the next
time because putting them in like
different positions within this world of
they built this utopia where everything
can be good and peaceful in harmony but
then evil starting to seep in after
several years
you focus on like hella as his detective
character which i thought was great and
then getting a different dynamic with
hella and thor
like thor's personality is like yeah
it's kind of like what i can imagine
thor being like
yeah especially to his sister but i want
to see what else they do
with other characters now not just make
jokes but
what approaches they take and seeing how
they can cleverly weave very different
worlds together
yes and the sets they've composed for
this are so awesome
this is a very meta obviously it's very
self-aware but there's such creativity
involved in the set design that they've
built as
well because like in the other ones the
super villains and all that super
showdown you know it's all in the
stadium
and like while they might do some cool
things here there with locations
this is all all outside the stadium yeah
it's a whole new world yeah
oh man i i had no idea that we were
walking into this
such a treat merry christmas to us all
like by the time it ended i was like
what no
yeah keep going artspear entertainment
you guys have outdone yourselves
guys subscribers if you haven't done so
already i don't know how they just two
people do this
and the voices are great yeah and
distinct from each other
hit the like button that's a link in the
description box to watch the video if
you haven't seen it already
catch you guys soon